beaucoup Quentin ettant dit que l'on
voit sortir gerérard Larcher président
du Sénat président de séance du cabinet
de départ et qu'il traverse la galerie
des bues à l'instant pour rejoindre bien
l'hémicycle du Sénat on va nous
rejoindre Audrey Audrey quels sont les
principaux thèmes de cette première
séance de question au gouvernement alors
les thèmes ça va être la conférence de
presse du Président hier il y aura
évidemment des réactions des réactions
avec des questions posées à Gabriel Atal
car trois présidents de groupe ont prévu
de l'interpeller Gabriel Attal qui est
arrivé dans l'hémicycle Cécile cuerman
pour les communistes Patrick canner pour
les socialistes et Claude maluré le
président du groupe les indépendants qui
lui poseront des questions et vous savez
quand il pose des questions c'est le
premier ministre qui
répond merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications vous l'avais dit
plusieurs questions sont prévues donc
autour du remanimement et la politique
générale le bol va s'ouvrir d'ailleurs
avec une question de la présidente du
groupe communiste c'est Cécile
cuquierman qui va donc ouvrir la
première question et c'est Gabriel Attal
le nouveau Premier ministre qui va lui
répondre ça va être aussi l'occasion et
bien notamment d'entendre parmi les
nouveaux ministres on va entendre et
bien le ministre des Affaires étrangères
Stéphane séjourné qui va s'exprimer pour
la première fois question sur la
situation à Gaza je vous rappelle que
nous avons toujours un gouvernement
resserré 15 minutes dont trois ministres
délégués séou et tout de suite donc on
prend la direction de l'émicycle avec la
S la prente été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je nen vois point le procèsverbal
est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage Monsieur le Premier Ministre au
nom du Sénat tout entier je tiens à
nouveau à vous féliciter pour votre
nomination et à vous souhaiter la
bienvenue au sein de notre assemblée
dans vos nouvelles fonctions depuis le
début de la législature votre
prédécesseur madame ellisabeth borne a
témoigné lors de nos séances de
questions d'actualité d'une présence
constante à laquelle nous avons été je
vous l'ai dit particulièrement sensible
et que je tiens une nouvelle fois à
s'allever je souhaite également la
bienvenue aux membres du
gouvernement avec une attention
particulière pour la ministre en charge
des relations avec le Parlement Marie-
Lebec Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres le
Sénat est le reflet de nos territoires
dans leur diversité sur ces B sièg des
élus expérimentés à l'écoute de nos
concitoyens nos collectivités
territoriales je forme donc le vœu
monsieur le Premier ministre que soyez
attentif au Sénat je crois que le
bicaméris j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
hier soir est une chance pour la
démocratie et l'équilibre de nos
institutions Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je rappelle
que la séance s retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au cours
de nos échange à des valeurs qui sont
pour nous très importantes le respect le
respect des uns et des autres mais aussi
le respect du temps de parole et je vais
donner la parole tout de suite à madame
la Présidente Cécile Garman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyens
et écologiste kaki madame la Présidente
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier ministre
mes chers collègues Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous tentez d'incarner un
changement mais la seule nouveauté c'est
que ce remanimement marque l'ancrage
dans votre nouveau monde de casse du
service public un monde fait pour les
riches un monde d'oppression pour les
salariés un monde qui exclut au lieu de
rassembler cette politique génère une
crise démocratique profonde d'ailleurs
le président de la République n'a
toujours pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale cette question
n'est ni politicienne ni secondaire
c'est le socle du fonctionnement de nos
institutions vous ne pouvez plus faire
jouer l'autoritarisme en abusant de 493
comme en 2023 vous engagez-vous à user
de cet article ou laisser faire le débat
parlementaire monsieur le Premier
ministre c'est le gouvernement qui
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation selon l'article 20 de la
Constitution et non le président de la
République c'est fondamental car si le
gouvernement se mu en UNAB d'exécutant
sans vote de confiance du Parlement
c'est l'édifice institutionnel qui
s'effondre Emmanuel Macron prend tout en
main des rencontres de Saint-Denis
jusqu'à hier lors de sa conférence de
politique générale mais il n'est pas
responsable devant le Parlement vous
devez donc Monsieur le Premier Ministre
demander un vote de confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale comme l'indique
l'article 49-1 de la Constitution et au
vu du rôle du Sénat face au blocage de
l'Assemblée nationale vous devez aussi
vous soumettre à son vote en déclenchant
l'article 49-4 y compris au regard de la
place que le Sénat a pris ces derniers
temps en commission mixte paritaire
aujourd'hui c'est la confusion la
gesticulation médiatique pour masquer
l'accélération autoritaire de la
politique libérale notre peuple a besoin
de reprendre la main a besoin de clarté
à soif de justice votre mandat doit être
soumis au vote des représentants du
peuple sinon vous serez qu'illusion je
vous repose la question monsieur le
Premier ministre allez-vous engager la
confiance pour vous répondre la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs madame la Présidente
kckerman c'est la première fois que j'ai
l'occasion de m'exprimer devant le Sénat
en tant que Premier ministre et vous me
permettrez donc de vous dire que et je
l'ai dit au président Larcher que j'ai
eu au téléphone le soir de ma nomination
nous nous sommes revus depuis
j'ai un très grand respect et même je le
dis une très grande admiration pour le
travail qui est mené ici au Sénat j'ai
pu le mesurer dans différentes fonctions
gouvernementales que j'ai occupé ces
dernières années en tant que secrétaire
d'État à la Jeunesse porte-parole du
gouvernement davantage pour les
questions d'actualité des longues nuits
sur le projet de loi de finances avec le
rapporteur Husson avec le président
renal avec chacune et chacun d'entre
vous et puis au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse évidemment
avec le président Lafond notamment mais
aussi beaucoup d'entre vous extrêmement
mobilisés sur ces question là j'ai
toujours été je le crois très à l'écoute
de ce qui était porté par les sénatrices
et par les sénateurs du fait de
l'expérience qui est la vôtre de la
représentativité qui est la vôre de nos
territoires dans leur très grande
diversité des propositions parfois
déétonnante et c'est aussi pour ça que
nous nous réunissons en tout cas
toujours constructive et c'est vraiment
l'état des esprit qui m'anime et que je
poursuivrai ici euh avec vous j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire je ferai ma
déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale le 30 janvier
prochain parce que je souhaite d'ici là
pouvoir rencontrer l'ensemble des
groupes représentés au Parlement
président de présidentes de groupe les
forces vives de la nation les
organisations syndicales les
associations d'élus locaux je souhaite
aussi me rendre sur le terrain dans des
échanges très directs avec les Français
avant la présentation de cette
déclaration de politique générale vous
m'interrogez madame la Présidente sur
une question qui relève de l'Assemblée
nationale mais je vais évidemment y
répondre j'ai d'ailleurs et nous y avons
d'ailleurs déjà répondu est-ce qu'il y a
une majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale non nous le savons est-ce
qu'il y a besoin d'un vote pour le
démontrer non je ne crois pas non plus
est-ce qu'il y a des Français qui se
lèvent le matin en se demandant est-ce
qu'il y aura ou pas un vote sur la
déclaration de politique générale du
Premier ministre je ne crois pas non
plus je pense qu'il y a des Français qui
se lèvent le matin en attendant de
savoir ce que nous allons faire pour
valoriser le travail des classes
moyennes qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de leur responsabilités et
qui attendent qu'on agisse pour elles
pour réarmer nos services publics et
notamment l'école et la santé pour
assurer la sécurité en tout lieu sur le
territoire et pour agir pour la
transition écologique c'est ça les
préoccupations des Français et pour le
coup c'est peut-être une révélation que
je vous fais ça sera au cœur de la
déclaration de politique générale que je
ferai à l'Assemblée nationale comme
c'est vous le savez l'usage cette
déclaration sera lue ici au Sénat en
même temps que je la prononcerai à
l'Assemblée nationale mais j'ai proposé
au Président Larcher nous ne sommes pas
encore reparlés mais j'ai proposer c'est
peut-être moins l'usage de venir dans la
foulée de cette déclaration de politique
générale devant vous pour prononcer une
intervention propre au Sénat évidemment
sur les enjeux que je viens d'évoquer
qui concernent tous les
Français mais je crois que la situation
que traverse notre pays les défis que
traverse le monde et en tout cas l'état
d'esprit qui est le mien commande que
nous puissions avoir un débat ensemble
ici au Sénat et c'est l'engagement que
je prends devant vous je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Hervé Moret pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
Monsieur le Premier Ministre hier le
président de la République a évoqué lors
de sa conférence de presse un grand
nombre de sujets allant de l'école à la
santé du pouvoir d'achat à la sécurité
entre autres il n'en revanche pas ou
peut évoquer un sujet qui nous paraît
pourtant important la situation de nos
finances publiques nous connaissons
pourtant un record de dett qui nous met
sur le podium européen des pays les plus
endettés une charge de la dette qui va
bondir de 50 % d'ici à 2027 et un
déficit qui sera le deuxème plus
important de la zone euro un certain
nombre des annonces du président vont
même encore aggraver cette situation
avec la généralisation du service
national universel qui pourrait coûter
plus de 3 milliards par an et la baisse
de 2 milliards des impôts mes questions
sont donc très simples à combien
chiffrez-vous les annonces du président
de la République comment comptez-vous
les financer quelles sont les intentions
réelles du gouvernement en terme de
maîtrise des finances publiques souvent
évoqué mais jamais
réalisé bonjour répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'économie et des
finances Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire merci monsieur le
Président profiter de cet accueil
allez-y j'ai peur que ça ne dure pas
tout le temps mais j'en profite pour
vous adresser à mon tour mes meilleurs
vœux à tous les sénateurs présents et au
présidents du Sénat c'est
sénatrice sénatrice et
sénateur monsieur Moret nous nous
connaissons bien nous avons été élu du
même territoire pendant une quinzaine
d'années et vous savez que j'ai
l'habitude de faire les choses en temps
et en heure nous avons en
2017 avec les gouvernements précédents
rétablir nos finances publiques j'avais
dit que nous reviendrions souer 3 % de
déficit que nous sortirions de la
procédure pour déficit public excessif
j'ai tenu par
avons ensuite à faire face à de crises
successives majeur le covid et la crise
inflationniste vous toutes et vous tous
ici vous avez appelé à une protection
capacités de production protection
salariés protection PME TP nous l'avons
fait vous avez appelé une protection des
plus modestes face à la crise
inflationniste à la flambé des prix du
gaz et du prixélectricité nous l'avons
fait maintenant nous revenons à la
normale nous sortons d'une situation
exceptionnelle et je partage totalement
votre ambition et je tiendrai parole
nous devons rétablir nos finances
publiques accélérer le désendettement du
pays et réduire nos déficits pour tenir
la première marche de 2024 4,4 % de
déficit et accélérer ensuite et je crois
avoir dit les choses très clairement il
y a quelques semaines en matière de
finances publiqu le plus dur est devant
nous allons devoir prendre des décisions
fortes et courageuses pour établir nos
finances publiques et comme je sais que
vous avez très bien écouté le président
de la République hier vous aurait noté
qu'il en a déjà annoncé au moins deux la
première il a confirmé que nous allions
sortir du bouclier énergétique sur le
gaz comme sur l'électricité parce que je
l'ai dit hier ici au Sénat à situation
exceptionnelle mesure exceptionnelle
mais dès lors que nous sortons de la
situation exceptionnelle il faut revenir
à la normale et mettre fin au bouclier
énergétique sur le gaz et sur
l'électricité il l'a fait également sur
la franchise qui va passer de 50
centimes à 1 € sur les médicaments
j'aurai l'occasion sur la base des
revues de dépenses publiques de proposer
au Premier ministre et au président de
la République des décisions fortes et
courageuses je n'ai aucun doute monsieur
le sénateur que vous les
soutiendrez monsieur
Moret merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre bon vous avez pas
tout à fait répondu à mes questions mais
je je ne m'attendais pas à une autre
situation j'ais simplement dire qu'il me
paraît difficile en matière de finances
publiques d'être dans le en même temps
on peut pas parler d'indépendance
financière comme l'a fait le président
de la République et continuer à dépenser
et à s'endetter chaque jour davantage
vous avez récemment dit qu'il faudrait
faire 12 milliards d'économie le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que les
mesures évoquées par le Président de la
République ou celle évoqué par le
Premier ministre qui a annoncé 32
milliards supplémentaire pour la santé
ne vont pas dans le bon sens et de toute
évidence la valal ce des milliards
continue et la loi de programmation des
finances publiques à peine voté semble
déjà Cadu je voudrais juste rappeler que
le Sénat lors de la du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 avait proposé 7
milliards d'économies et 2 milliards de
recettes supplémentaires dont le
gouvernement n'a pas tenu compte donc je
ne peux pour conclure qu'inciter le
gouvernement comme l'a fait le président
du Sénat à l'égard du Premier ministre
hier soir à écouter davantage les
proposition du Sénat je vous remercie
merci ma parole est à notre collègue
madame pmche pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ce remanement
gouvernemental acte la continuité d'une
ligne politique de droite mais nous
aurons le temps de le questionner une
fois la feuille de route présentée mais
la situation à Gaza
elle ne peut plus attendre en 100 jours
1 % de Gazaoui a été tué soit un taux de
mortalité quotidien supérieur à celui de
n'importe quel conflit armé du 21e
siècle sans compter les personnes
ensevelies blessées 95 % de la
population déplacée lors de la récente
audience à la Cour internationale de
justice concernant la saisine de
l'Afrique du Sud contre Israël une des
avocates a déclaré c'est le premier
génocide de l'histoire où les victimes
diffusent leur propre destruction en
temps réel dans l'espoir désespéré
jusqu'à présent 20 que le monde quelque
chose nous savons vous savez la France a
la responsabilité et l'obligation en
tant qu'État parti aux convention
internationales de protéger et de d'agir
pour mettre un terme au crimes de guerre
au crimes contre l'humanité voire au
génocide en cours à Gaza comme partout
dans le monde et sans double standard en
Ukraine comme en Palestine se joue la
défense des principes fondamentaux du
droit international et l'avenir de
l'Europe le massacre de civil doit
cesser quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour faire respecter le droit
international et ses résolutions vous
engagez-vous à appuyer et à faire
appliquer les mesures conservatoires
demandées à la CIJ vous engagez-vous à
saisir la Cour pénale internationale
comme les écologistes vous y invitent
par le dépôt d'une résolution pour
qualifier les faits tous les faits et
poursuivre les auteurs de crimes
comptez-vous décider l'embargo sur les
vente d'armes à Israël enfin Monsieur le
Ministre quand comptez-vous reconnaître
l'état palestinien comme voté par notre
Parlement et soutenir l'Espagne dans
cette demande auprès de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
européenne pour vous répondre la parole
est à la monsieur le ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Stéphane sjourné à qui je
souhaite la bienvenue dans cet hémicycle
merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur le
Président Madame la S atrice je veux
d'abord rappeler peut-être la la
solidarité de la France avec Israël
suite à à l'attaque terroriste de lundi
elle a fait au moins un mort 17 blessés
parmi lesquels deux de nos compatriotes
deux Français rien ne serait justifié le
terrorisme rien et je veux également
avoir une pensée pour tous les otages et
nos 41 compatriotes assassiné le 7
octobre nous leur rendrons hommage le 7
février prochain comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République hier
s'agissant de la situation à Gaza elle
s'aggrave de façon
dramatique dans cette guerre l'action de
la France se fonde sur trois piliers
fixés par le Président de la République
le volet sécuritaire vous l'avez dit
avec une lutte contre le terrorisme qui
passe par l'adoption prochaine d'un
régime de sanctions européennes contre
le Hamas dès lundi notamment au Conseil
des Affaires étrangères humanitaire
ensuite avec le respect du droit
international avec in cess le feu durame
nécessaire pour permettre l'acheminement
de l'aide la France a d'ors et déjà
déployé 1000 tonnes de nourriture et
d'équipement et 100 millions d'euros
pour les populations palestiniennes et
enfin Madame la la sénatrice politique
en vue de retracer les perspectives de
deux états ce sujet sera d'ailleurs au
cœur de la réunion du Conseil de
sécurité que je présiderai le mardi 23
janvier à New York enfin il nous faut
éviter l'escalade régionale la France
œuvre en ce sens au Liban en mer Rouge
et bien sûr en sjordanie alors vous
l'avez vu réponse sécuritaire
humanitaire politique réponse nationale
et réponse européenne et international
ce qui se joue au ProcheOrient est trop
est trop important pour être ignoré par
notre PS il faut éviter évidemment le
pire merci
merci la parole est maintenant au
président François Noël buffet pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains voilà le micro est branché
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à vous Monsieur le Premier
Ministre à l'occasion des discussions
sur le texte immigration une partie du
débat s'est noué autour de l'aide
médicale
d'État pendant ce débat le gouvernement
avait demandé à monsieurs evvin et
stéphanini de rendre un rapport ce qui a
été fait et puis sous la plume de votre
prédécesseur madame le Premier ministre
le 18 décembre dernier engagement a été
pris par le gouvernement de proposer
déposer un projet de loi en ce début
d'année 2024 pour aborder cette
thématique question enfin plus
exactement hier devant l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez confirmé monsieur le
Premier ministre que cette démarche
serait faite et donc ma question est
très très
simple allez-vous d'abord déposer ce
projet de loi sur la base simplement du
rapport déposé par Monsieur stéphanini
et Evin ou allez-vous ouvrir
préalablement la discussion avec le
Parlement et singulièrement avec le
Sénat et si oui finalement quand et
comment allez-vous procéder pour que
nous Contin d'avancer sereinement je le
redit sereinement sur ce texte
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le Président buffet à
l'occasion des débats sur le projet de
loi immigration je n'étais pas dans les
fonctions que j'occupe aujourd'hui
j'étais membre du gouvernement et j'ai
pu évidemment observer ces débats j'ai
bien vu que la question de l'aide
médicale d'État a fait l'objet de
questions et de discussion
légitime je le dis il n'est pas
illégitime de s'interroger sur tout ou
partie de nos dispositifs publics et de
notre modèle social c'est aussi pour ça
que nous sommes élus ou que nous sommes
nommé au gouvernement c'est pour
réinterroger en permanence notre modèle
et je le dis l'aide médicale médicale
d'État a fait l'objet de questionnement
de de réinterrogation et d'évolution
sous des majorités de gauche comme des
majorités de droite et comme des
majorités comme celle qui nous
rassemblent autour du président de la
République j'ai le souvenir qu'en 2014
c'est un souvenir vous l'imaginez assez
proche que à l'époque le gouvernement et
la ministre de l'époque Marie sol Touren
déjà avait posé un certain nombre de
questions notamment sur les filières qui
abusaient de ce dispositif et que des
évolutions étaient intervenues dans des
débats
parlementaire et dans le précédent
mandat dans le précédent quinquena il y
a eu aussi des des évolutions sur la
question du palier de soins de manière
je dois le dire assez dépassionnée et
c'est ça la logique qui doit je crois
nous animer c'est regarder les
dispositifs tels qu'ils sont et regarder
comment nous pouvons les améliorer et
c'est en ce sens qui a été confié vous
l'avez rappelé une mission à Claudé vin
et Patrick stéphanini qui ont travaillé
je crois dans cet état d'esprit là et je
pense qu'il est important de rappeler il
a été rendu public que le rapport
indique d'abord que l'aide médicale
d'État est un dispositif utile
globalement maîtriser je crois que c'est
les termes qui sont employés et qui ne
constituent pas en tant que tel je fais
attention aux mots que j'utilise un
levier d'incitation à lui seul à
l'immigration pour autant est-ce que
cela éteint toutes les questions non et
d'ailleurs le rapport lui-même vous
l'avez dit fait plusieurs
recommandations plusieurs propositions
qui me semblent assez intéressantes et
légitimes à partir de là comment on
avance vous le savez la première
ministre a adressé un courrier et
d'ailleurs président du Sénat m'a aussi
interrogé sur les suites que que
j'entendais donner à cet engagement la
première ministre s'engageant à donner
une suite à ce rapport par des mesures
réglementaire ou législative hier j'ai
été interrogé à l'Assemblée nationale
vous l'avez rappelé sur les suites que
nous allions donner et surtout sur le
fait de savoir si je me considérais
engagé par la lettre de ma prédécesseur
ellisabeth borne j'ai répondu
qu'évidemment je respecterai
l'engagement qui a été pris par la
première ministre ensuite comment est-ce
qu'on va le faire c'est ça votre
question sur ce sujet-là je vous demande
de patienter quelques jours ou semaines
nous sommes vous le savez dans
l'installation du nouveau gouvernement
je dois en échanger évidemment avec le
ministre de l'intérieur avec la ministre
du Travail des solidarités et de la
santé et vous l'avez noté tout à l'heure
je présenterai ma déclaration de
politique générale le 30 janvier je
viendrai par ailleurs spécifiquement au
Sénat pour échanger sur tous les sujets
également donc l'engagement sera tenu
évidemment nous donnerons une suite à ce
rapport sur les modalités sur le
calendrier je reviendrai vers vous très
prochainement après avoir travaillé avec
mon gouvernement sur les suites que nous
donnerons
merci monsieur le Président
buffet merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour cette réponse vous avez
dit il y a quelques jours que vous étiez
un adepte du constat de vérité c'est au
moins une conviction que nous avons en
commun dans ces conditions là le Sénat
en tous les cas la majorité sénatoriale
et le groupe que je repr lequel je
m'exprime c'est après-midi est prêt à un
travail approfondi sur ce sujet-là en
rappelant deux choses la première chose
c'est que le principe du soin pour les
personnes susceptibles de bénéficiaires
de laame n'est pas remis en cause et la
deuxième chose c'est que notre volonté
c'est de maîtriser le dispositif et de
le contrôler de façon à être efficace
quant à son rôle qui lui est défini et
qu'il ne soit pas dévoyer de l'objet qui
lui a été promis
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Nicole
Duranton pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressiste et
indépendant vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères dans le contexte de
la guerre entre Israël et le Hamas la
tension est montée en mer Rouge ces
dernières semaines avec des attaques des
outils visant le trafic maritime en
solidarité avec la bande de Gaza cette
voie stratégique qui relie la
Méditerranée à l'océan Indien est
crucial pour le commerce mondial avec
20000 navires la traversant chaque année
depuis mi-octobre cette route
commerciale est menacée par les outil
des rebelles yéménites membres d'une
organisation soutenue par l'Iran voulant
interdire le passage au navir des pays
qu'ils estiment être proche d'Israël
cette milice yeminite a rejoint la
coalition informelle appelée axe de la
résistance réunissant notamment l'Iran
le Hamas et le hzbollah contre l'État
d'Israël cette coalition fait planer le
spectre d'un conflit
généralisé la France fait partie de la
coalition internationale assurant la
sécurité en mer Rouge en décembre
dernier la frégate langdoc en mission en
mer Rouge patrouillant dans la zone a
abattu en légitime défense des drones se
dirigeant vers elle ces attaques outil
dissuadent les navires commerciaux
d'emprunter la mer Rouge il se détourne
du canal de sueze optant pour le Cap de
Bonne Espérance cette route alternative
rallonge considérablement leur trajet ce
qui résulte en une hausse du tarif des
transports ces attaques menacent la
libre circulation du commerce et viole
le droit international pour la France la
liberté de navigation en mer Rouge est
d'une importance cruciale pour ses
intérêts ne serait-ce que pour assurer
les liaisons maritimes avec ces
territoires de l'océan Indien Mayotte et
la Réunion
cette situation
aggrave l'inflation sur leurs
importations la crise en mer Rouge n'est
pas qu'un danger sur le plan sécuritaire
c'est aussi un danger commercial avec
des répercussions qui entraînent une
pression inflationniste sur la France
l'Europe et qui pénalise l'économie
mondiale monsieur le ministre face à
cette double menace sécuritaire et
commerciale en mer Rouge quell mesurees
envisagez-vous pour protéger les
intérêts commerciaux et économiques de
la France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères mon séjourné merci Monsieur
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice Nicole Duranton oui les outils
menacent la sécurité maritime et le
commerce international en mer Rouge ces
attaques sont une atinque à nos intérêts
nationaux et européens un navire CMA CGM
et la frégate langdoc ont d'ailleurs été
directement ciblé plusieurs compages
maritime vous l'avez dit vous-même sont
contraints de contourner cette zone ces
attaques sont aussi une violation
évidente du droit internationale la
résolution adoptée le 10 janvier par le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
les condamne et rappelle le droit des
États à se défendre contre ces menaces
face à ces menaces la France agit en
détruisant directement les drones
dirigés contre des navires qui sont
civils ou qu'il soient
militaires dans ce contexte les
États-Unis ont fait le choix d'une
opération militaire sur les territoires
contrôlés par les outils la France n'a
pas souhaité prendre part à ces
opérations à ce stade nous nous
contentons de mener une action en mer et
en total une autonomie d'ailleurs
parfaite en coordination avec nos alliés
nous étudions d'ailleurs les moyens de
renforcer la présence européenne en mer
Rouge voilà notre approche madame la
sénatrice fermeté dans le cadre
collectif et en même temps si je peux me
permettre des escalades par le dialogue
l'escalade et la et de la seule
responsabilité aujourd'hui des outils et
notre responsabilité est d'éviter un
embrasement supplémentaire dans la
région
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Claude maluré pour le groue
les indépendants
répuoire
après vous avoir félicité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pour votre nomination
je voudrais évoquer les propos de votre
Ministre des Affaires étrangèr à Kiev
déclarant que l'aide à l'Ukraine restera
une priorité il faut maintenant tenir
cette promesse la situation est devenue
critique les crimes de guerre du boucher
du kremelin infligent chaque jour un
atroce supplice à la population civile
d'Ukraine les Ukrainiens qui ont
brillamment contre-attaqué à carquiv et
kersonne en 2022 sont aujourd'hui en
position de faiblesse parce que depuis
le début le soutien des démocraties peut
se résumer par la formule trop peu trop
tard si nous avions livré à temps les
chars les missiles les batteries
anti-aériennes l'armée russe n'aurait pu
reconstituer ses défenses et faire
échouer la contreofensive de 2023 nous
sommes en train de renouveler cette
erreur depuis des mois Zelenski attend
les 60 milliards de dollars de
Washington bloqué par les trumpistes au
Congrès et les 50 milliards d'euros de
l'Europe paralysé par ces colonne Orban
le collabo en Hongrie Le Pen et
Mélenchon les chiens chiens à leur
Poutine en France et tant d'autres
ailleurs nos tergiversations mettent
l'Ukraine en grand danger je pèse mes
mots une défaite serait celle de
l'Europe tout entière un formidable
stimulant pour la Chine face à Taïwan
pour le Docteur Folamour de Corée du
Nord pour les Moras iraniens tueurs de
femmes au Moyen-Orient il serait
impensable que le prochain Conseil
européen du 1er février ne déjoue pas
les manœuvres d'Orban le corrompu et ne
débloque pas la totalité de l'aide
promise à l'Ukraine je vous demande
aujourd'hui l'engagement formel d'y
parvenir et de soutenir sans restriction
le fond d'investissement européens en
défense de 100 milliards proposé par le
commissaire français Thierry Breton en
ce début de mandat vous vous dites sans
doute monsieur le Premier ministre que
vous serez jugé sur vos résultats dans
notre pays et c'est exact mais à
l'échelle de l'histoire votre
gouvernement et tous les gouvernements
de l'Europe seront jugés à l'ône de la
victoire ou de la défaite des
démocraties en en Ukraine face à
l'international reconstitué des
[Applaudissements]
dictateurs Monsieur le Premier
[Musique]
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le Président
maluret il y a près de 2 ans en dépit de
toutes les règles de droit international
et de tous ses engagements la Russie a
agresser l'Ukraine c'est une attaque
cynique
meurtrière avec des frappes aériennes
répété qui vise explicitement les
civils ce qui est en jeu dans ce conflit
et je vous remercie de l'avoir rappel
aussi clairement c'est la liberté c'est
la démocratie et c'est l'avenir de notre
continent la Russie espère que l'Ukraine
cèdera et que ses soutiens se leront et
je le dis de manière très claire en tant
que chef du gouvernement et le président
de la République l'a rappelé hier la
Russie se trompe comme l'a rappelé le
président de la République nous ne
faiblirons pas et nous ne faiblirons
jamais notre détermination est intacte
et je le réaffirme ici devant vous le
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères s'est rendu à Kief vous le
savez c'était son premier déplacement
après sa
nomination permettez-moi pour la
première fois en tant que que Premier
ministre au nom du gouvernement et en
votre nom à tous j'en suis sûr de dire
mon admiration pour le peuple ukrainien
et de saluer son courage
exceptionnel monsieur le Président
maluret vous avez évoqué notre soutien à
l'Ukraine je le disais à l'instant il ne
faiblira pas le président de la
République a annoncé hier la livraison
de nouveaux missiles de longue portée et
de centaines de bombes ce sont des
armements attendus par les ukrainiens et
qui seront déterminants sur le terrain
en parallèle nous continuons à former
des militaires Ukrainiens comme nous
l'avons fait depuis le début du conflit
pour répondre à leurs besoins nous
poursuivrons donc notre soutien
militaire en concertation avec nos
partenaires j'ajoute que notre soutien
humanitaire continue lui aussi pour
répondre aux besoins les plus immédiats
du peuple ukrainien notamment en matière
d'éducation et de santé pour réussir la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs est
essentiel je pense évidemment à l'état
je pense aux collectivités locales don
je veux saluer aussi l'engagement
remarquable beaucoup interviennent
évidemment en solidarité avec les
Ukrainiens je pense aussi aux acteurs
privés engagés en soutien l'économie
ukrainienne ou déjà évidemment pour la
reconstruction notre soutien de long
terme à l'Ukraine civile comme militaire
sera inscrit dans l'accord bilatéral de
sécurité que le Président de la
République signera avec le président
zelanski lors de son déplacement à Kief
en février ce soutien de la France le
président de la République aura
l'occasion de le réaffirmer vendredi à
cherbour en adressant ses vœux à nos
armées j'ajoute et vous l'avez abordé
aussi que la France porte également la
mobilisation en faveur de l'Ukraine au
niveau européen nous sommes déterminés à
obtenir un accord sur la facilité
Ukraine au Conseil européen
extraordinaire du 1er février déterminé
concrètement cette facilité doit
permettre à l'Ukraine de faire face à a
ses besoins de financement immédiat et
de mener les investissements essentiels
pour se reconstruire et se moderniser
l'Union européenne est également
déterminé à poursuivre son soutien
militaire à l'Ukraine le Conseil
européen de décembre dernier a ainsi
demandé que s'intensifi les travaux sur
la réforme de la facilité européenne
pour la paix en s'en prenant à l'Ukraine
la Russie a attaqué nos valeurs la
Russie a remis en cause la démocratie et
la liberté nous nous tiendrons au côtés
de l'Ukraine et du peuple ukrainien
nous nous tiendrons toujours au côté de
nos valeurs c'est une de nos priorités
elle le reste je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Nathalie de l'intre pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture mes chers
collègues il y a 4 ans jour pour jour
lors de notre séance des questions au
Gouvernement notre collègue Muriel
Jourda interroga le ministre de de
l'agriculture de l'époque Didier
Guillaume sur la manière dont il
comptait venir en aide aux
austriculteurs alors durablement touché
par des pollutions de l'eau au
neurovirus lors des fêtes de fin d'année
de 2019 Madame Élisabeth Bourne alors
ministre de la transition écologique
rappelit que dans le cadre du 11e
programme d'intervention des agences de
l'eau 3,6 milliards d'euros d'aide
seraiit accordé au titre du traitement
des EAU us
comment et où ces fonds ont-ils été
employés car force de constater que les
mêmes causes ont produit les mêmes
effets ont témoigne l'interdiction de la
vente d'hîre du bassin d'Arcachon prise
par arrêté préfectoral le 27 décembre
dernier en raison de la contamination de
la production au
neurovirus le préfet a réuni autour de
lui les collectivités et les
établissements publics compétents dans
la gestion des eaux usées et des eaux
pluviales sur le bassin versant il a
promis d'accélérer les programmes
d'investissement pour apporter des
réponses à moyen et long terme il y a
quelques jours le ministre Christophe
Béchu toujours là m'indiquait suite à un
courrier que je lui avais adressé que
l'État pourrait intervenir sur des aides
à l'investissement sauf qu'il n'est pas
pour leure question d'investir mais il
est question pour ces austriculteurs de
survivre la fermeture pour 28 jours de
la totalité de la zone de production du
bassin d'Arcachon a entraîné 5 millions
d'euros de perte sèche et la crainte de
perdre la confiance des consommateurs
aussi au côté des aides aux
collectivités annoncé comment allez-vous
aider directement monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture nos austriculteurs et
nos austriicultrices et serez-vous
adjoint d'un ministre dédié à la mer
tant les enjeux en la matière sont
vastes
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
fau vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de re vous avez raison c'est
un sujet récurrent qui est celui des
difficultés élé notamment au traitement
des EAU usées c'est parce qu'on sait que
c'est le la cause principale et vous
l'avez rappelé à
l'essue d'épisodes pluviométriques
intense de débordement de stations
d'épuration et des opérations d'léestage
sur les
réseaux réseau de d'eau pluviale qui
était saturé ont conduit à la
propagation du neurovirus qui produit
des infections humaines de type
gastroentérite de nature aigu ce qui
justifie des mesures de protection qui
ont été prises d'ailleurs par la
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation ces
interdictions temporaires sont destinées
à protéger la santé de des consommateurs
ce qui reste et je crois que les
austrcuteurs l'ont dit avec grande
responsabilité la priorité évidemment
absolue dans ces cas-là mais elles ne
sont pas liées du tout ces
difficultés-là au cas la qualité du
travail des austrculteurs vous l'avez
rappelé d'une certaine façon si les
coquillages contaminés peuvent à nouveau
être commercialisés une fois le virus
éteint à la suite d'un épisode de
filtration dans des eaux saines le
préjudice économique et le préjudice
d'image c'est-à-dire le préjudice
médiatique est important une nouvelle
fois
puisque les producteurs ne sont en rien
responsabl la possibilité de mobiliser
des mesures de soutien ça avait été dit
et ça a été dit par Hervé Berville de
mobiliser des mesures de soutien é à
l'étude certaines ayant déjà été activé
par le passé on verra s'il y en a pas
d'autres à mobiliser je pense à des
exénéations de la redavance domaniale et
les choses qu'on peut faire en matière
fiscale ou en matière de charge sociale
nous le verrons avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances nous le
verrons aussi sur les sujets des
collectivités local avec Christophe
Béchu vous l'avez vous l'avez cité en
effet sur ces sujets là il convient de
souligner que le d'abord le plein
exercice du principe de pollueur payeur
euh et je suis un élu local qui sait à
quel fois parfois c'est difficile de
développer des projets mais là il y a
une responsabilité pollueur payur
deuxième élément c'est d'accélérer sur
les investissements ça n'a sans doute
que trop tardé il faut qu'on accompagne
les collectivités c'est sans doute pas
aussi simple que cela et c'est le
travail que vous avez nommé qu'on va
accélérer avec la préfecture de ces
zones les préfectures parce qu'il n'y a
pas que dans votre département
malheureusement que ça s'est développé
pour avancer accélér indemniser dans le
court terme et accélérer les process
d'investissement dans le moyen et long
terme merci de la parole est maintenant
au président Patrick canner pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre dans un
exercice assumé
d'autosatisfaction le président Macron
hier m'a rassuré notre pays va bien
l'ascenseur sociale fonctionne et nos
services publics ont les moyens de
remplir leur mission j'ai sans doute été
distrait car pour moi la réalité était
toute autre dans ma réalité l'école
publique est fragilisée par des
professeurs non remplacés désabusés
l'hôpital public s'effondre j'ai en tête
l'exemple tristement emblématique de la
maternité Jeanne de Flandre à Lille qui
transfère une partie de ses patient et
de leur bébés en Belgique dans ma
réalité la France compte désormais près
de 5 millions de pauvres et la classe
moyenne a de plus en plus de mal à
joindre les debouts le déclassement
social frappe de plus en plus nos
concitoyens dans ma réalité le logement
traverse une crise d'une ampleur inédite
depuis 30 ans sans disposer à ce stade
d'un ministre de plein exercice monsieur
le Premier ministre il faut ouvrir les
yeux voilà l'état de la France et vous
en êtes comptable les propos du
président de la République traduisent sa
déconnexion avec le quotidien des
Français pour lui c'est la moralisation
et l'ordre pour les citoyens la la
dérégulation et le désordre pour les
intérêts financiers ce n'est pas
l'optimisme dont il a fait preuve hier
soir il cultive une amnésie politicienne
pour conserver ce mauvais cap fixé il y
a bientôt 7 ans les français eux n'ont
rien oublié ni l'injuste réforme des
retraites ni la stigmatisation des
chômeurs ni la xénophobie rampante de la
loi immigration Monsieur le Premier
Ministre aurez-vous la lucidité de poser
ce constat aurez-vous l'audace d'en
tirer toutes les
conséquences pour vous répondre la
parole est au Premier
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateur monsieur le Président canner
bon manifestement nous n'avons pas
assisté à la même conférence de presse
en tout cas j'y étais avec mon
gouvernement et je crois que les
Français qui nombreux ont assisté à
cette conférence de presse par la
télévision au contraire au contraire
entendu un président de la République
lucide sur les difficultés de notre pays
et sur les défis que nous avons à
relever est-ce que la lucidité est-ce
que la lucidité sur ces difficultés doit
nous
empêcher de reconnaître et de mettre en
avant un certain nombre de progrès qui
sont intervenus ces dernières années
dans notre pays moi je ne crois
pas je pense que sur la question du
chômage avec un taux de chômage aussi
bac nous ne l'avions pas connu depuis un
certain nombre d'années dans notre pays
quand même on peut quand même se dire
que c'est un progrès mais pas un progrès
pour le gouvernement pas un progrès pour
le président de la République un progrès
pour ces des millions de Français qui
ont pu retrouver un
emploi quand on voit le décollage de
l'apprentissage dans notre pays avec
bientôt 1 million de jeunes qui chaque
années sont en apprentissage on peut se
dire que c'est un progrès pas pour le
gouvernement pas pour le président de la
République mais avant tout pour tous ces
jeunes qui vont pouvoir trouver leur
voie grâce à
l'apprentissage quand on voit un certain
nombre de droits qui ont été ouverts
dans notre pays ces dernières années à
l'initiative du Président de la
République et de la majorité je pense
par exemple à l'ouverture de la PMA pour
tout les femmes on peut se dire qu'il y
a eu un progrès pas pour le gouvernement
le président de la République mais pour
toutes ces femmes qui vont pouvoir
s'engager dans un projet familial je
pourrais multiplier un certain nombre
d'exemples est-ce que ça me rend aveugle
ou sourd aux difficultés que traversent
les Français et à la situation du pays
la réponse est non et je crois l'avoir
dit dès ma prise de fonction à Matignon
lors de la passation de pouvoir je suis
lucide sur les difficultés sur les
angoisses sur les inquiétudes sur les
doutes les colèes de beaucoup de
Français et même sur les Français qui
n'expriment pas de colère tout
simplement parce qu'ils n'attendent plus
rien j'en suis conscient je sais que
tous ces Français qui tous les jours
vont travailler qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de leur responsabilité qui
ont toujours le sentiment d'être
au-dessus de ce qu'il faut pour être
accompagné par la solidarité nationale
et en dessous de ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir s'en sortir tout seul ils
attendent beaucoup de nous je suis
conscient que les Français attendent
évidemment beaucoup en matière de santé
accès au soins et d'hôpital et je le dis
monsieur le Président canner c'est s de
tous j'ai été membre du Parti socialiste
j'ai travailler auprès de la ministre
des Affaires sociales et de la santé
monsieur le Président canner je le dis
les budgets et l'investissement qui ont
été dédié à l'hôpital public depuis 2017
à travers le segéure de la santé mais
pas seulement on en aurait rêvé dans les
précédentes majorités on en aurait rêver
dans les précédentes majorités c'est ça
la réalité ça n'était pas les arbitrages
qui étent rendu à l'époque financier il
y a eu un choix qui a été fait clair
résolu de soutenir l'hôpital mais
évidemment l'argent ne suffit pas et ce
qu'il faut c'est que poursuivre la
transformation poursuivre un travail sur
les coopérations pour l'accès aux soins
de tous les Français et c'est le mandat
de Catherine V trin évidemment que sur
la question de l'école il y a de
nombreux défis encore à relever et j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire ces derniers
mois quand j'occupais le poste de
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse je pense que j'ai montré que
j'étais capable de porter un constat
lucide sur les difficultés de notre
école et aussi de prendre un certain
nombre de premières décisions assez ferm
et assez radicales sur la question de la
laïcité à l'école qui ne doit jamais
souffrir d'aucune contestation et qui
doit être en tout lieu de notre
territoire respecté j'ai pris cette
décision extrêmement claire dès ma prise
de fonction sur la remise de
l'excellence et de l'exigence à toutous
les niveaux à l'école parce qu'on ne
peut pas accepter que pour certains
l'école soit devenue une forme de tapis
roulant sur lequel on se pose et on
glisse de classe en classe sans vérifier
si on a le niveau pour passer dans la
classe supérieure c'est pour l'égalité
des chances qu'on remet de l'exigence et
de l'excellence à tous les niveaux et
c'est le mandat de la ministre qui
poursuivra évidemment cette action et
déclinera le choc des savoirs que j'ai
eu l'occasion d'annoncer oui je suis
lucide aussi sur les difficultés en
matière de sécurité pour nos concitoyens
lucide sur le fait que nous avons
recruté 14000 postes de policiers de
gendarmes supplémentaires depuis 2017
que nous avons investi comme jamais dans
la justice avec un garde des saau partic
ulrement tonique pour obtenir des
budgets supplémentaires pour son
ministère j'ai pu le voir en tant que
ministre des comptes publics et oui là
aussi il y a des enjeux de
transformation à poursuivre pour que le
service public de la justice soit
toujours au rendez-vous des Français
enfin je suis lucide aussi sur ce qui
nous reste à accomplir pour la
transition écologique et la protection
de la planète je suis Premier ministre
et je suis aussi en charge de la
planification écologique de notre pays
comme ma prédécesseur et oui j'aurais à
cœur d'appliquer même d'accélérer avec
mes ministres sur la feuille de route
présentée par par le Président de la
République sur la planification qui nous
place là aussi comme un pays moteur en
matière d'ambition de transition
écologique j'entends les critiques et
les questions qui sont posées mais
j'attends qu'on me montre un pays de
l'Union européenne qui s'engage autant
que nous qui a réussi à réduire de 4 %
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comme nous l'avons fait l'an dernier
quel pays a réussi à faire pareil dans
l'Union européenne un pays qui a le
niveau d'émission de CO2 par unité de
production aussi faible que le nôtre en
France dans les pays comparables qu'on
me le présente je vais pas faire ici ma
générale en tout cas vous voyez que
j'avais des choses à vous dire j'ai des
choses sur le cœur et je suis sûr que
nous aurons de très beau débat ici tous
ensemble au Sénat monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
je ne doute pas de votre sincérité
simplement je vous dis comme je le pense
changer de premier violon ne change pas
la
partition et quand le président de la
République vous qualifie de soldat de l'
2 l du premier Conseil des ministres
situé à côté de son bureau à
l'Élysée je ne voudrais pas que ces
soldat l' de la République qui ont sauvé
la République se transformment demain en
cavalier de l'apocalypse ceux qui
permettront que l'extrême droite puisse
s'installer dans ce pays et votre
politique malheureusement est en train
d'y
concourir la parole est à notre collègue
Max Brisson pour le groupe les
républicain merci Monsieur présid ident
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse des sports et des Jeux
olympiques et
paralympiques j'espère madame n'avoir
oublié aucune de vos fonction lors de la
passation rue de Grenet le vendredi
dernier le Premier ministre affirmé
l'école sera la mère des batailles de
mon gouvernement le président l'a
confirmé hier j'ai donc trois questions
à vous poser à la lumière de votre large
portefeuille concrètement comment
comptez-vous conseiller concilier de
manière efficace et permanente la
bataille de la refondation de l'école et
en même temps le défi de l'organisation
des Jeux de Paris dans cette même dans
cette m des batailles quelle image du
professeur entendez-vous porter dans la
société quelle est votre vision de son
rôle de sa place de son autorité dans
cette mer des batailles quel rôle et
quelle place entendez-vous donner à
l'enseignement privé sous contrat et
hors
contrat pour vous répondre la parole est
à Madame UDA casterra madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Brisson en réunissant les
champs de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports dans notre
contexte olympique et paralympique vous
n'avez rien oublié le président de la
République et le Premier ministre m'ont
confié un continuum de responsabilités
aux synergies qui sont en effet
nombreuses mais au cœur de ce continuum
il y a une ambition le réarmement
civique de notre jeunesse et il y a un
trésor c'est l'école alors pour la
servir je m'appuierai sur trois piliers
d'abord restaurer l'exigence à travers
le choc des savoirs impulsés par Gabriel
Atal et à travers la réaffirmation de
l'autorité de nos professeurs sur la vie
de classe sur leur enseignement sur les
décision de redoublement et sur les
notations deuxième pilier renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers de
l'enseignement en réinventant la
formation initiale des enseignants en
repensant leur formation continue en
continuant d'améliorer l'organisation et
les remplacements de courte durée en
poursuivant les réformes engagées pour
la revalorisation des carrières et des
conditions de travail cell des
enseignants mais aussi d'autres
catégories de personnel comme les
infirmières scolaires les assistants
sociaux et les Aes troisième pilier
construire plus que jamais dans la
France des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques une école de
l'épanouissement républicain où la peur
et le harcèlement n'ont plus leur place
une école dans laquelle tous les élèves
s'approprient les valeurs de la
République avec l'instruction civique le
respect de la laïcité et l'engagement à
travers le SNU une école inclusive
monsieur le sénateur et attentive au
bien-être et à la santé de tous nos
enfants une école ouverte sur la société
avec la découverte des métiers au
collège les stages de seconde la
nouvelle carte des formations pour les
lycéens professionnels une école enfin
qui sait reconnaître les singularités de
nos enfants et faire grandir leurs
talents notamment oui par le sport par
l'art et la culture une détermination
faire réussir la jeunesse faire réussir
toutes les écoles de notre pays je vous
remerci monsieur Brisson madame la
ministre moi je vais vous parler du
zigzag que le Président de la République
fait subir à notre école Jean-Michel
Blanquer parler laïcité autor et
confiance avant de constater impuissant
une malgré une avalanche de circulaire
la dégringola de notre école PAP ensuite
passer par-dessus bord les principes
chers à son prédécesseur et s couvert de
mixité sociale à saper les derniers
espace d'excellence de notre école
Gabriel at l'enfer qui durant 5 mois et
20 jours nous a offvert une offre une
ode quotidienne à l'école dont nous
attendons toujours la traduction dans
les actes au lieu de de zigzag ne
serait-il pas temps de fixer un cap et
de s'y tenir dans la durée avec pour
valeur centrale la liberté l'autorité le
mérite l'excellence et la performance
telle est la mère des batailles à mener
mais avec un tel portefeuille madame la
ministre cette MRE des bataille sous le
poids de vos responsabilités ne
risque-t-elle pas plutôt de finir
noyer
merci la parole est à notre collègue
audreé bellim pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républiain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la réunion
a connu pour la première fois depuis 30
ans le passage de l'œil d'un cyclone je
profite de ce moment pour exprimer ma
solidarité aux Mauriciens durement
touché également à l'heure où nous
parlons le bilan humain fait état de
quatre décès sur le plan matériel de
nombreux réionnis sont sinistrés les
récoltes des agriculteurs a été
fortement impacté par le cyclone je
salue l'action des élus locaux qui ont
ouvert dans des délis contraints 158
centres d'hébergement d'urgence pour les
populations les plus fragiles mais
également l'action du Préfet et du
gouvernement vendredi devait être
annoncé la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle comme demandé par
l'association des maires du département
de La Réunion que j'ai soutenu pour
l'instant la réunion a tenue mais Béal
n'est qu'un avertissement de plus la
prévention des risques et la préparation
face aux crises doivent être renforcé à
court terme se pose la question de
l'accompagnement des collectivités par
exemple à Saint-Denis les dépenses post
cyclone s'élèvent à 6 millions d'euros
et ce sans les travaux sur le bâti à
moyen terme se pose la question de la
résilience de notre territoire de
nombreux réonnais n'ont plus accès à
l'électricité et donc plus accès à l'eau
non plus les budgets liés au réseau de
distribution d'électricité sont-ils à la
hauteur des besoins comment se fait-il
que les fil éctrique ne soit pas enterré
alors que la Réunion est une terre de
cyclone ce n'est pas une surprise ce
n'est pas imprévisible une succession de
cellules de crise ne pourra pas faire
une politique se pose aussi la question
de notre lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique nous l'avons vu dans le Pas
de calis nous le voyons aujourd'hui à la
Réunion les tempêtes et cyclones vont se
multiplier et s'aggraver qu'allez-vous
faire pour accélérer en matière de
transition énergétique alors même que le
ministère de plein exercice a été sup
la question n'est donc pas de savoir ce
qui a été fait mais bien ce que vous
allez faire
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
la ministre déléguée chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement madame pr Teven vous avez
la parole bienvenue merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice à mon tour
effectivement au nom du gouvernement je
me permets de saluer ici la résilience
et la force de capacité d'engagement
aussi bien des habitants de l'île de la
Réunion mais également des forces de
secours de sécurité effectivement
également de nombreux secouristes
engagés auprès des associations et des
élus locaux il est évident je me permets
aussi de saluer ici en solidarité les
habitants de l'île Maurice qui a
également qui ont également été frappés
par ce cyclone permettez-moi de de
répondre très rapidement mais avec
précision aux différents éléments
importants que vous avez interrogé
l'alerte rouge a effectivement été levée
par le préfet hier à 13h heure locale à
cette heure les actions de
reconnaissance se poursuivent et les
débléement des voiries ont débuté les
coupures d'électricité d'eau et de
réseaux téléphoni fixes comme mobile ont
été importantes mais sont en cours de
réparation les principaux réseaux de
communication routière ont été réouverts
à la circulation seul les réseaux
secondaires et la voie d'accès à silaos
à Siloas pardon doivent encore faire
l'objet de travaux de déblaement sur le
plan humain nous déplorons quatre
victimes le président de la République a
décidé l'engagement de moyens nationaux
ainsi que des sapeurs pompiers des
sapeurs sauvteurs des gendarmes et les
agents d'enedis sont partis en renfort
de métropole mais également de Mayotte
l'aide de l'État va se poursuivre avec
une procédure accélérée de
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle dont la Commission devrait se
réunir dès demain madame la sénatrice
avec l'appui du préfet et l'ensemble des
disposit positif d'appui aux population
exploitant du monde agricole ou
industriel touché par ce cyclone vont
être activés tel que le dispositif de
calimité agricole ou le fond d'aide
outreem par ailleurs vous soulevez un
point important c'est dans capacité
d'anticiper et de continuer à renforcer
nos capacités de travailler sur ces
enjeux climatiques qui sont de plus en
plus fréquents et forts bien évidemment
la France y prend toute sa part mais
également au niveau européen un groupe a
été mis en place pour travailler à ces
enjeux-l et notamment la France aura une
voix particulière au regard de sa
capacité à témoigner de de ces
territoires d'outrem
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Anne chin Larcher pour le
groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues monsieur le Premier
ministre en 2023 la France a compté
seulement 678000 naissances en un an
c'est une baisse de 7 % en 13 ans une
chute de 20 %. ce crash de la natalité
est destructeur pour notre économie et
notre système social il constitue une
menace existentielle pour notre pays
puisque le renouvellement des
générations n'est plus assuré le recours
à une immigration massive pour compenser
ce déficit de naissance serait une très
grave erreur cela risquerait de détruire
la cohésion nationale le nombre
d'enfants désirés par les familles reste
là largement supérieur aux naissances la
responsabilité du gouvernement est
immense que s'est-il passé ces dernières
années le cocient familial a été renié
les allocations rabotées les coûts de
garde d'enfant augmentés la prestation
jeunes enfant diminué et j'en passe
c'est une véritable guerre contre les
familles qui a été menée et nous en
payons le prix l'annonce d'un congé de
naissance de 6 mois sans en connaître
les moyens est encore à côté de la
plaque d'autant plus qui entraînerait la
suppression du congé parental actuel de
2 ans ce qui aggraverait les problèmes
de garde d'enfant pour de nombreuses
familles alors ma question est simple
quelle est votre politique
familiale la parole est à la ministre
déléguée porte-parole du gouvernement
madame t merci monsieur le Président je
me permets d'excuser Catherine vain qui
est en ce en ce moment même pardon à
l'Assemblée pour des débats madame la
sénatrice effectivement la France accuse
cette année une baisse de natalité sans
précédent les raisons sont multiples
quand le désir d'enfant est présent
baisse de la fertilité lié à l'arrivée
plus tardive du premier enfant
difficulté d'accès au mort de garde mais
également baisse de fertilité liée à des
facteurs exogènes des mesures ont d'ors
et déjà été annoncé mise en œuvre en
2023 allongement du congé paternité à 25
jours mise en en place de l'entretien
prénatal et post-natal précoce
investissement massif dans la recherche
contre l'infertilité dans le cadre de
francerance l'infertilité qui d'ailleurs
je préfère ici aussi le rappeler n'est
pas simplement du fait des hommes des
femmes mais touche également les hommes
et il est important de le rappeler pour
pouvoir le traiter nous avons leevé par
ailleurs le tabou de l'endométriose qui
est la première cause d'infertilité
féminine et qui touche une femme sur 10
il faut aujourd'hui aller plus loin dans
l'accompagnement des parents ce sont
200000 solutions de garde nouvell qui
doivent être trouvées d'ici la fin du
quinquena la nouvelle convention
d'objectif et de gestion qui lit l'État
à la knaf prévoit près de 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires consacrés à la
petite enfance d'ici 2027 nous allons
également accélérer la lutte contre la
pénurie de professionnels de la petite
enfance et renforcer l'attractivité des
métiers c'est l'enjeu des
revalorisations salariales annoncé que
nous allons mettre en œuvre en lien bien
évidemment avec les branches et les
communes enfin le président de la
République a annoncé hier la mise en
place d'un nouveau congé de naissance
plus court mieux rémunéré que le congé
parental actuel il permettra d'augmenter
le temps de présence auprès des enfants
sur les 1000 premiers jours de la vie
sans pénaliser les ménages sur le plan
financier et en rééquilibrant la charge
dans le couple je vous
remercie madame
chalarcher alors je m'adresse à ce
nouveau gouvernement arrêtez de dépenser
de l'argent public à coût de chèque et
de subvention bidon mais investissez
pour la petite enfance et le pouvoir
d'achat soutenez financièrement et
fiscalement toutes les familles fait
coexister congé parental court bien
rémunéré et congés longs moins rémunérés
soutenez la création de places de crèche
et redonner un ministère à la famille ce
sont les familles d'aujourd'hui qui
préparent la France de demain il faut
leur redonner espoir et confiance agitez
vite agissez vite et fort où notre pays
disparaîtra
la parole est maintenant à la présidente
Sylvie Vermeillet pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
au matin de Noël puis du Nouvel An
Gabriel Brémont maire desclan deenom
dans le Jura découvre des tags partout
dans le village et sur les murs de sa
mairie sal travelot le maire s'envoie
en l'air nique ta mère le maire Gabriel
en porte
Bremont t de con des injures homophobes
attaqu personnel d'une violence inouï
qui choque encore tout un village et
bien au-delà du jurat Gabriel bréont est
un maire sans histoire apprécié de ses
administrés il est solide il a déposé
plainte et fait face mais comment les
témoignages de sympathie de ses
administrés lui apporte un réconfort
salutaire ainsi que ceux des maires de
toute la France qui témoignent de la
solidarité des membres de cette grande
famille républicaine qu' a choisi de
servir et qui n'en finit pas d'être
maltraité 2600 agressions l'an passé 50
% de plus qu'il y a 2 ans et malgré les
indignations les textes votés la dérive
est implacable
insupportable monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez rappelé à Dijon le
weekend dernier nous sommes un
gouvernement qui va continuer d'agir
contre les discriminations contre
l'homophobie et en faveur des droits de
tous voyez-vous que les auteurs de ces
attaques démontrent que leurs auteurs
n'ont ni peur des forces de l'ordre ni
peur de la justice notre République ne
sait pas protéger ses mares monsieur le
ministre qu'allez-vous changer pour
qu'il soit
respter pour vous répondre la parole est
à Monsieur H dupom garde des saau
ministre de la
Justice merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice
Sylvie vermeiller je pense que nous
sommes tous à cet instant unis par la
même
indignation par la même colère par la
révolte face à cette agression
doublement
infâme doublement parce que c'est une
agression homophobe et parce qu'elle
vise un
élu je dois dire à cet instant au Mair
des clans nénon
tout le soutien du gouvernement auquel
j'appartiens vous le savez madame la
sénatrice dès mon arrivée à la
Chancellerie j'ai pris un certain nombre
de circulaires
clair pour demander expressémente à tous
les procureurs de notre pays une réponse
systématique une réponse ferme une
réponse rapide le budget que vous vous
avez voté les trois budgets que le Sénat
a voté et je l'en remercie nous
permettent désormais d'envoyer des
personnels supplémentaires magistrat
greffiers contractuel devenus attachés
de justice et à Besançon une cour
d'appel dont je sais madame la sénatrice
qu'elle vous est chère c'est 58 de ces
personnels qui vont arriver j'ai par
ailleurs demander à tous les procureurs
de ce pays de dire aux élus quels
l'issue de la plainte qu'ils ont déposé
nous avons mis en place par ailleurs
grâce au contractuel devenu attaché de
justice un lien qui doit être un lien
privilégié entre les élus locaux et les
parquets et pour vous rassurer
totalement même si bien sûr on déplore
le nombre d'agressions qui existe je
veux vous donner quelques chiffres si
vous m'y autorisez en 2022 mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs le taux de
réponse pénale des infractions commises
contre les élus s'élève à 98 %. à
gravité égale pour des faits de violence
le taux prononcé d'un emprisonnement
ferme et de 51 % lorsque la victime est
un élu 25 % lorsque la victime n'est pas
un élu et enfin le taux de déferrement
est CIN fois plus élevé le taux de
mandat de dépôt quatre fois plus élevé
quand la victime est un élu soyez
assurés madame la sénatrice mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs que le combat
continue que nos efforts dans la défense
des élus est total bien évidemment comme
notre engagement parce que s'attaquer à
un élu c'est s'attaquer à la
[Applaudissements]
République madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le gardessau
pour vos propos mais je crois que tous
ici nous constatons encore et énormément
de plaintes qui sont classées sans suite
donc effectivement la clé c'est la
fermeté et la clé c'est la sanction en
face de toute agression merci très
bien la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence müerbron pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le Conseil d'analyse économique rattaché
au Premier ministre a révélé la semaine
dernière que l'étiquette énergie des
logements de A à G qui définit
aujourd'hui leurs valeurs et les
autorise ou non à être loué repose en
réalité sur des calculs purement
théoriques et sur une modélisation très
approximative ainsi le fameux diagnostic
de performance énergétique DPE
transformé en quête du Graal climatique
pour lequel l'État investit des
milliards ne reflète pas la consommation
réelle des logements ni les les prétendu
gain énergétiqu attendu or c'est bien
lui qui aggrave aujourd'hui une crise du
logement sans précédent notamment pour
les locataires et les propriétaires les
plus modestes depuis le 1er janvier 2023
tous les logements classés G+ sont
interdits à la location et cette
décision repose sur un algorithme biaisé
que dites-vous monsieur le ministre aux
propriétaires et aux locataires qui en
font déjà les frais si on persiste dans
les d échéances annoncées 11000 mil de
logements classés F et G vont être
interdits à la location dans les 10
années à venir sans véritable raison une
fois de plus cette machine à exclure
retombera sur les mers eux-mêmes
dépassés par la pénurie des logements et
les contra les contraintes liées à la
construction monsieur le ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour supprimer et
remplacer cet outil défaillant qui
paralyse le secteur du logement pour
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de la transition écologique et et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
munerbrun le rapport du Conseil
d'analyse économique auquel vous faites
référence du 10 janvier vous l'avez
résumé à grand trait parce que ce n'est
pas exactement ce qu'il dit ce qu'il dit
c'est qu'il y a une différence entre la
consommation théorique et la
consommation réelle et pour faire simple
que plus les gens sont dans des passoirs
moins ils chauffent et qu'à l'inverse
des gens qui sont dans des logements
très
peuvent avoir tendance à utiliser ce
qu'on appelle un effet rebond et donc
avoir des températures moyennes plus
élevées et des factures plus élevées et
donc que la baisse des émissions est
parfois moins forte compte tenu de
l'impact sur les factures et ça n'est
pas sur 1000 personnes c'est sur 160000
logements l'analyse du CAE conclut au
fait que les étiquettes sont cohérentes
autrement dit a c'est mieux que B qui
est mieux que c qui est mieux que D et
je vous invite à lire le rapport pas
seulement les articles de presse qui
sont parus autour et ensuite de préciser
que c'est un outil qui même si mesure un
biiais sur les attitudes ne modifie pas
l'analyse de ce qui a été refondu en
2021 un nous avons besoin de faire des
travaux de rénovation pour des enjeux
climatiques mais aussi pour des enjeux
de pouvoir d'achat vous parlez des
propriétaires vous parlez des locataires
un locataire dans une passoire
énergétique en moyenne deux fois plus de
factures que quelqu'un qui est dans un
bien qui est deux classes en dessous de
vous évoquez les chiffres qui mélangeent
les propriétaires occupants des
logements vacants plus de 10 % dans les
passoirs énergétiques des résidences
secondaires et des locatifs qui sont les
seuls à être concerné par un calendrier
d'interdiction tris vous évoquez des
marges d'amélioration il y en a
plusieurs la formation des
diagnostiqueurs et des annonces que je
ferai dans quelques jours pour corriger
les biaiss des DPE sur les petites
surfaces des biens de moins de 40 m² sur
lequel là nous avons matière sur la base
du rapport du CAE mais pas seulement à
améliorer le dispositif le Premier
ministre m'a autorisé dans quelques
jours à faire en sorte de préciser ces
nouvelles
règles madame
Bub monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'on base une
politique majeure sur des modélisations
un peu fumeuse les Français perdent une
nouvelle fois confiance dans cet état
qui s'appuie sur un dispositif qui n'est
bienveillant ni pour eux ni pour la
planète hier j'ai entendu comme beaucoup
d'entre nous le président de la
République qui s'est inquiété de la
baisse de la natalité or la première
sécurité pour élever des enfants c'est
bien le logement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Colom brossell pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale al vos propos ont choqué
heurté blessé la communauté éducatif
parlons école parlons de l'école de la
République l'école publique laïque
gratuite et obligatoire cette école
c'est celle qui scolarise 80 % des
élèves de ce pays d'où qu'ils viennent
qui qu'ils soi c'est vers elle que votre
énergie devrait être tournée afin de
garantir la réussite de T ce la comme
personnel car les défis sont immenses et
vous êtes au pouvoir depuis plus de 6
ans vous avez de fait posé la question
des parts de marché mise en concurrence
entre l'enseignement public et
l'enseignement privé cette mise en
concurrence n'est même pas libre et non
faussée aucun contrôle n'est effectué
par l'état des fonds publics qui
financent l'école privée et ce alors que
l'enseignement privé est financé à plus
de 70 % par l'État la Cour des comptes
très récemment vous rappelit à vos
obligations en la matière alors madame
la ministre quel moyen allez-vous enfin
donner à l'école publique pour la
renforcer pour vous répondre la parole à
la ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports madame oua
Castera merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice je crois vraiment on
doit pas opposer l'école publique et
l'école privée depuis la loi Debray du
31 décembre 59 adopté sous la présidence
du général de Gaulle qui établit la
liberté d'enseignement dans notre pays
notre pays vit et notre pays vit bien
avec des écoles publiques et avec des
écoles privées les premières accueil 100
millions d'élèves les autres 2 millions
soit un élève sur 6 et toutes deux
concours service public de l'éducation
dans les établissements privés je le
rappelle les programmes et volume
horaire sont ceux du public dans
l'ensemble des établissements sous-
contrat les enseignants sont rémunérés
par l'État et recrutés avec les mêmes
exigences de qualification que dans le
public 50 % des familles ont eu recours
au moins une fois à l'enseignement privé
pour au moins un de leurs enfants alors
je crois qu'il faut respecter ses choix
de scolarisation ne pas les stigmatiser
ne pas forcer les parents d'élèves à se
justifier mais comprendre ce qu'il y a
derrière leur décision et faire en sorte
que le choix d'une école publique ou le
choix d'une école privée ne soit pas la
résultant de déception ou de frustration
mais qu'elle correspondent ces décisions
à des vrais choix d'adhésion pour tous
au libre arbitre de chacun pour l'école
publique madame la sénatrice j'ai la
plus grande des ambitions d'abord
l'exigence à travers le choc des savoirs
l'autorité renforcée de nos professeurs
à travers toutes les réforme que je vais
poursuivre suite aux impulsions données
par Gabriel Atal sur la revalorisation
des carrières sur les conditions de
travail sur l'organisation de nos
remplacements pour l'école privée je
veux veiller à ce qu'ell soi toujours et
partout au rendez-vous des principes et
des valeurs de la République et qu'on y
renforce aussi souvent que nécessaire le
contrôle pédagogique et que dans tout
notre service public de l'enseignement
on assure la cohérence de l'offre
éducative et la mixité sociale et
scolaire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs réussir l'école avec toute la
communauté éducative nous allons le
faire nous allons le faire faire réussir
toutes les écoles de notre pays je vous
remercie madame la
sénatrice merci pardon madame la
ministre peut-être que c'est pas d'usage
de parler avec son cœur dans un
hémicycle mais pardon de vous dire à
quel point il est troublant que vous so
soyez incapable de répondre à la
question simple que je vous ai posée
vous vous êtes mise toute seule dans une
situation qui est faite de polémique et
de mensonge et votre impuissance
aujourd'hui celle que vous projetez elle
est délétaire pour l'école elle est
délétaire alors que les enfants les
enseignant l'ensemble des personnels les
parents ont besoin de force ont besoin
de confiance les solutions elles
existent recruter des profes remplaçant
dans le primaire pour que on ait des
remplaçants pour les absences de courte
durée annuler toutes les suppressions de
postes qui ont été proposé ici même
pendant le budget
2024 la mixité mais enfin on l'a fait
vivre dans nos territoires quand on fait
des secteurs multicollèges quand on
adosse le financement privé à la mixité
sociale et scolaire prenez vos
responsabilités et faites vivre enfin
l'école de la République l'école de la
confiance c'est la confiance dans
l'école l'école de la confiance c'est la
confiance dans l'école
publique la
parole
est au président Jean-François rappin
pour le groupe les républicains monsieur
le
Président Monsieur monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre à partir du 22
janvier et pour une durée d'un mois des
centaines de pêcheurs français seront
empêchés d'exercer leur activité dans le
golfe de Gascogne 600 navires sont
concernés ce mois s'empêche pour les
français contrairement à leurs collègues
de l'Union européenne proposé par le
gouvernement et durci par le Conseil des
état sous la pression des associations
environnementales
entant préserver les populations de
petit cétacés des prises accidentelles
ce mois s'empêche c'est un nouveau coûp
porté à toute une filière qui depuis des
années tente de surmonter un à un les
obstacles qui se dresse face à elle
entre les impacts du brexit et la mise
en place d'un plan de sortie de flotte
entre l'envolé des prix du gasoil des
quotas de plus en plus restrictifs et
des importations en hausse constante
c'est bien la pêche française qui est
désormais en voie de disparition nos
marins leurs familles et demain toute la
filière aliotique vont continuer à
souffrir malgré tous les efforts qu'on
senti depuis 30 ans il s'équipent
progressivement pour palier à toutes les
contraintes qu'on leur impose
l'incompréhension les gagn ne veut-on
pas valoriser le travail et ils sont
empêchés de travailler et paradoxe
naissant en Bretagne on réfléchit à
importer par avion du poisson pêché à
8000 km de nos côtes la plateforme
d'indemnisation qui a été mise en place
pour compenser le manque à gagner des
pêcheurs atténuera partiellement la
douleur elle ne concernera pas toute la
filière elle ne guérira pas la maladie
compensé n'est pas une perspective
d'avenir monsieur le ministre après
l'industrie et l'agriculture avec la
pêche encore un fleuron français garant
de l'autonomie qui souffre il est grand
temps de changer de cap qu'avez-vous à
dire aux pêcheurs et à leur
famill pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le Président
rppin l'émotion dont vous faites part
elle est d'abord née d'une décision du
Conseil d'État le 22 décembre dernier et
vous n'êtes pas en train de commenter ce
que serait une décision gouvernementale
mais au contraire la censure par le
Conseil d'État d'une tentative de
concilier ce qui éta à la fois un enjeu
de préservation de la biodiversité avec
un risque de disparition du Dauphin et
du marsoin commun et de l'autre la
possibilité de poursuivre une activité
de pêche qui participe à notre
souveraineté le compromis il avait
consisté à la fois à tenir compte d'une
mesure d'arrêté
spatio-temporelle en permettant des
dérogations qui étaient lié à des
équipements simplement controverse
scientifique sur l'impact de ces
équipements certains répulsifs sonores
comptenu de l'intelligence du dauphin
étant accusé de provoquer le fait que
les dauphins se rapprochent des bateaux
équipés des répulsifs au lieu au
contraire de s'en éloigner et les
chiffres monsieur le Président sont
préoccupants avec plus de 1000 échouages
le consensus c'est que c'est entre 5000
et 10000 c'est assez qui meurt et à ce
niveau de mortalité les risques sur la
viabilité d'une espèce qui participe euh
aussi à l'ensemble de l'équilibre dans
le Gold de gastcogne sont réels et
avérés pour la survie de
l'espèce face à ça et face à cette
décision du 22 décembre le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est comment accompagner
une filière et comment dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent construire
trouver un équilibre en ayant à la fois
le souci de la biodiversité et celui que
vous décrivez de ces femmes et de ces
hommes dont je n'ignore pas parce qu'il
s'agit pas seulement d'un gagnepin mais
d'une philosophie d'une vocation d'une
façon de vivre c'est l'ambiance des
pororts je pense évidemment à ceux que
vous connaissez je pense à la vandé je
pense au golf de Gascogne de manière
générale ce sont des centaines de
bateaux de plus de 8 m qui sont
concernés nous nous battons en ce moment
et nous allons nous battre pour la
partie compensation mais nous aurons
très vite à nous retrouver avec les
représentants des pour au-delà de ce
mois de fermeture spatiau-temporelle
regardez les choses de façon plus posée
et plus constructive pour le moyen terme
monsieur le Président
rap merci merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez répondu techniquement à ma
question je vous en remercie mais
néanmoins je pense que au-delà de ce que
vous avez exposé il y a bien sûr l'enjeu
des familles et finalement sur le
littoral sur tous les territoires la
question de la pêche elle est elle est
valable dans le golf de Gascogne et
demain elle sera à nouveau un sujet
d'actualité prignant avec le brexit sur
la mancheste mer du Nord et la Bretagne
donc monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui
les enjeux liés à la mer n'ont-ils pas
valeur suffisante pour avoir un ministre
un ministère de plein
exercice la parole est à notre collègue
Nadia solgou pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Agriculture il y a un an
exactement un texte était adopté à
l'unanimité des deux chambres ici au
Sénat au cours de la discussion générale
précédant son adoption Olivier dussot
alors ministre du Travail avait dit au
nom du gouvernement nos agriculteurs et
agricultrices plus largement les
Français et les Françaises nous
attendent sur cet horison de justice
sociale ce texte c'était celui qui
visait à calculer la retraite de base et
non salarié agricole en fonction des 25
années d'assurance les plus avantageuses
et non plus sur l'ensemble de la
carrière cette loi promulguée le 14
février 2023 comporte un article unique
et dispose que dans un délai de 3 mois à
côté de sa promulgation le Gouvernement
remettra au Parlement un rapport
précisant les modalités de sa mise en
œuvre ce rapport présentera notamment le
détail des scénarios envisagés des
paramètres retenus pour son application
ainsi que le cas échéant les
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires qu'il convient de
modifier bref ce rapport doit donner
tous les éléments qui permettront à la
MSA de commencer cet énorme chantier or
à ce jour 1 an après pas de rapport dès
lors les associations professionnel
agricole et la MSA alerte sur le fait
que dans ces conditions le dispositif ne
sera probablement pas opérationnel dans
le délai prévu par la loi alors Monsieur
le Ministre aujourd'hui je relaye cette
question où en est ce rapport tant
attendu et quand sera-t-il remis au
Parlement je vous remercie bravo NAD
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur
F merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice sur group merci de votre
question ça me permet de faire un point
vous l'avez dit c'est un sujet important
parce que c'est un sujet à la fois de
justice c'est un sujet de reconnaissance
et puis aussi un sujet d'attractivité
d'ailleurs au moment où nous allons
parler de renouvellement des générations
vous dire déjà ce qui a été fait grâce à
vous d'ailleurs les lois chassigne 1 et
chassigne 2 des éléments qui ont permis
de revaloriser le minimum de pension de
75 à 85 % c'est 115 € de plus par mois
pour de près 200000 pensionnés de rendre
plus équitable le calcul de la pension
minimale c'est 200000 retraités qui sont
concernés retraités agricoles dont 70 %
de femmes on sait à quel point la
situation des femmes était très
défavorable sur les pensions agricoles
et puis la réforme des retraites portée
par Olivier du SOP effectivement qui a
permis aussi de revaloriser un certain
nombre de choses je pense aux
exploitants qui sont partis à la
retraite au titre de l'invalidité ou du
handicap et ces 45000 retraités qui sont
concern né là aussi donc on a avancé et
on a avancé collectivement et c'est
l'occasion de le dire et puis il y a le
projet de loi la proposition de loi
pardon de Julien div sur laquelle vous
attendit un certain nombre de réponses
je je dois à la vérité de dire que le
ministère de l'Agriculture interrogé à
l'époque sur le moment où nous pourrions
rendre le rapport avait dit 3 mois nous
pensons que ça va être une grande
difficulté pourquoi parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de données
qui manquaient on sait très bien la MSL
a dit qu'il y avait une difficulté à
reconstituer les carrières et que donc
ça serait assez difficile je suis en
mesure de vous dire que nous allons
pouvoir rendre public le rapport à la
fin du mois de janvier 2024 début du
mois de février pour être précis que on
ne croit pas que je veuille faire malice
sur ces sujets là mais il fallait du
temps pour le faire et donc on va faire
un certain nombre de propositions je
vrais dire que c'est évidemment un sujet
très complexe parce que quand on modifie
autant que cela sur les 25 années il y a
un risque qui est des perdants beaucoup
et des gagnants qui soient mal
identifiés donc c'est pour ça que ça
prend du temps j'assume qu'on a pris du
temps pour faire des choses en bon ordre
et des choses sérieus il y a deux pistes
qui peuvent être envisagé me semble-t-il
mais on en reparlera et vous serez
associé à ce travail la première c'est
c'est application de la réforme au seul
nouveaux entrants et puis procéder à une
double deième option procéder à une
double liquidation sur la base des
règles actuelles pour les périodes
antérieures à 2016 et pour les périodes
par rapport à après 2016 sur la période
sur les les références de 25 années
c'est là suus que nous travaillons et
c'est là suus que nous échangerons nous
allons approcher du but pour
effectivement rendre justice aux
agriculteurs
leoup écoutez monsieur le ministre je
suis très contente moi je m'apprêtais à
raller très fort dans ma réplique mais
alors tout va bien parce que c'est vrai
que fin janvier début février je je
m'attendais pas à une réponse aussi
favorable euh voilà vous avez compris
qu'on sera très attentif quand même
parce que chaque semaine qui manque là
on a quand même perdu beaucoup de mois
initialement la la réforme devait
s'appliquer au 1er janvier 2024on donc
on a quand même perdu du temps chaque
semaine va manquer à la MA c'est
extrêmement complexe donc maintenant on
attend que ça aboutisse très très vite
vous avez compris l'enjeu c'est
extrêmement important
merci mais Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions au Gouvernement nos prochaines
question auront lieu le 24 janvier à 15h
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour la désignation des
23 membres de la commission d'enquête
portant sur la production la
consommation et le prix de l'électricité
la séance est
suspendue
voilà pour cette séance inaugurale des
questions au gouvernement de 2024
c'était aussi la première séance de
questions pour gabrielal comme premier
ministre et on va d'ailleurs rejoindre
Audrey vetas dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
Audrey on a vu d'ailleurs Gabriel hatal
qui a voulu partir du bon pied avec les
sénateurs aujourd'hui oui avec une
séance de Cino thérapie à la Chambre
haute Gabriel Atal a profité de sa
première réponse pour saluer le travail
du Sénat souligner aussi les moments
qu'il a passé ici sur le banc en tant
que ministre pendant parfois de longues
heures
écoutez j'ai un très grand respect et
même je le dis une très grande
admiration pour le travail qui est mené
ici au Sénat j'ai pu le mesurer dans
différentes fonctions gouvernementales
que j'ai occupé ces dernières années
j'ai toujours été je le crois très à
l'écoute de ce qui était porté par les
sénatrices et par les Sénat
du fait de l'expérience qui est la vôtre
de la représentativité qui est la vôtre
de nos territoires dans leur très grande
diversité des
proposition parfois détonnante et c'est
aussi pour ça que nous nous réunissons
en tout cas toujours constructive et
c'est vraiment l'état d'esprit qui
m'anime et que je poursuivrai ici avec
vous vous le voyez Tam une ode au Sénat
Gabriel Atal qui a promis de venir à la
chambre haute le 30 janvier pour un
temps d'échange après son discours de
politique générale à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est important a-t-il dit
même si ce n'est pas une première loin
de là nous avons vérifié dans nos
tablettes et ellisabeth borne l'a déjà
fait elle était venue au Sénat dans la
soirée après son discours de politique
générale alors calinothérapie je vous
l'ai dit mais les sénateurs
l'attendaient tout de même au tournant
pour cette première avec notamment une
réaction à la conférence de presse du
Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron hier jugé beaucoup trop positive
par le président du groupe socialiste
Patrick canner Gabriel Atal qui semble
avoir préparé ces argument puisqu'il a
répété plusieurs fois qu'il était lucide
sur la situation du pays face au broua
du Sénat qu'il a un peu chahuté il a
tenu bon et il a même il en a même
profité pardon pour tacler son ancien
camp socialiste
écoutez je suis conscient que les
Français attendent évidemment beaucoup
en matière de santé d'accès aux soins et
d'hôpital et je le dis monsieur le
Président canner c'est su de tous j'ai
été membre du Parti socialiste j'ai
travaillé auprès de la min ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
monsieur le Président canner je le dis
les budgets et l'investissement qui ont
été dédiés à l'hôpital public depuis
2017 à travers le segéure de la santé
mais pas seulement on en aurait rêvé
dans les précédentes majorités on en
aurait rêvé dans les précédentes
majorité c'est ça la
réalité conclusion du président caner à
cette réponse du Premier ministre ce
n'est pas parce qu'on change le premier
violon qu'prenez Premier ministre qu'on
change la partition voilà th pour les
premiers pas de Gabriel Attal en tant
que Premier ministre aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explication effectivement en séance
inaugurale donc pour Gabriel Attal au
lendemain de la conférence de presse XXL
d'Emmanuel Macron dont l'objectif était
de relancer l'acte 2 de son mandat de
son quinquena on va débriefer également
tout cela en plateau avec Mélanie Vogel
sénatrice éc des Français de l'étranger
bonjour merci beaucoup